how does it feel
[Music]
finally home finally back in peter's
arms it's like there's no one else in
this packed terminal one emotional hug
just isn't enough max pulls peta in for
a sweet kiss and another long embrace
max what does it mean to be home but i
just don't want to resent peace
somewhere else because of what i just
saw and that's that's the reality i i
don't know really what to say right this
second honestly welcome home
we're glad you're safe brother we're
glad
always always
[Music]
peter kept the candlelight vigil for six
straight days and a source tells e.t she
spent a handful of nights crying herself
to sleep moments before he arrived an
anxious peta couldn't hold back the
tears waiting for her husband's safe
return from the middle of the war zone
[Music]
that place is no longer safe so
it's trying to process where i was
yesterday to where i am today
walking to their car there's a crush of
cameras and another hug as the
ukrainian-born star explains why he
risked his safety posting his location
amid the brutal onslaught i made that
choice and made that decision i decided
that this is my gun and i'm going to do
my best with this and and
and if that's not something that's
enough to protect me personally while i
was there well then let's be it
the 42 year old praised local ukrainian
reporters for broadcasting the reality
of the atrocities and became emotional
as he continued to rally against
vladimir putin he's losing
tremendously and so what he's doing now
is just like a baby with a tantrum he's
just throwing things and and it looks
very bad the reason why ukraine is
standing right now is because of
ukrainian people and the fact that the
entire world is helping outside nations
that just like
you know sending their own troops on
their own accord they're going to
ukraine and that's an incredible thing
and if we don't get involved this thing
is going to go everywhere else following
this action we have to completely
rethink the way we do things as a planet
and that there's never going to be one
person that can do something like this
ever again and with that message max was
off to finally reunite with his
five-year-old son shaw welcome home man
you know
[Music]